It really is the damnedest thing. Chris will tell you that himself. When he was in the army, when he was flying around in helicopters taking enemy fire, he was terrified. He never thought he'd look back on it later and miss anything about it.
这真的是最糟糕的事情了。克里斯本人也会这么告诉你。当他在军队时，当他驾驶直升机遭到敌方火力攻击时，他是恐惧的。他从未想过自己回头看时，会对那段经历有任何怀念。
At the time, no. I figured I'm not going to miss this. Why am I going to miss this? Somebody's constantly shooting at me, trying to kill me, trying to kill the guys that I'm working with. You've got to be out of your mind if you miss this. You know? But then, down the road, you think well, I really miss that excitement. I miss that danger.
当时，没有。我当时想我才不会怀念这个。我为什么要怀念这个？有人一直在向我开火，试图杀死我，试图杀死和我一起工作的人。如果你会怀念这种生活，那你一定是疯了。你知道吗？但后来，久而久之，你会想，我真的很怀念那种刺激感。我怀念那种危险。
I miss the action.
我怀念那种行动感。
Fred Sallatore came back from war and got a job selling insurance in Texas.
弗雷德·萨拉托雷从战争中回来后，在德克萨斯州找到了一份卖保险的工作。
The adrenaline rush is so great. And there are not many times you and I, in our walk of life, are in a situation where the decisions we make impact the lives and deaths of others.
肾上腺素飙升的感觉太棒了。而且在你我的人生旅途中，没有多少机会能让你处于那种你所做的决定会影响他人生死的境地。
And this is the thing I was really curious about is when you came back, did your regular life seem kind of stupid?
我真正好奇的是，当你回来时，你的正常生活是否显得有些乏味？
Yes. Not so much dumb or stupid, but boring. And there wasn't much to it. You get up at 5:30. And you're in the office by 7:30. And you go home about 6:30. And it's just anti-climactic, I suppose. And, when you're 23 years old, it's a little depressing, initially.
是的。与其说是笨或者愚蠢，不如说是无聊。而且也没什么意义。你5点半起床。7点半到办公室。6点半回家。我想，这有点虎头蛇尾。当你23岁时，起初会觉得有点压抑。
When did you find something that was as intense as the military to replace the military?
你什么时候找到了像军队那样强烈的替代品来填补军队生活的空缺？
I haven't.
我还没找到。
Fred's army service in Vietnam ended in 1967. Chris left Vietnam in '69, and it took Chris a while to figure out what to do with himself when he came home. Nothing felt right after what he'd been through. He went from job to job until he signed up with the Baltimore Fire Department.
弗雷德在越南的服役于1967年结束。克里斯在69年离开越南，他花了一段时间才适应回家后的生活。在他经历过那些之后，没有什么事情是感觉对劲的。他换了一份又一份工作，直到他加入了巴尔的摩消防局。
And let me tell you, when I got out of the fire academy and I was assigned to my first unit, and I had my very first fire, I was scared to death. My adrenaline was just pumping big time. And it was a cool feeling, believe it or not. It was a cool feeling. It was something that I had missed for a long, long time. And I know that sounds kind of strange, but the things that I hated the most were the things that I missed the most.
我告诉你，当我从消防学院毕业并被分配到第一个单位时，我经历了第一次火灾，我吓坏了。我的肾上腺素当时在狂飙。信不信由你，那是一种很酷的感觉。那是一种很酷的感觉。那是我怀念了很久很久的东西。我知道这听起来有点奇怪，但我最恨的事情反而成了我最怀念的事情。
It is a little strange, but I have to say it makes complete sense. At some point or another, all of us have been in some situation where all we could think about was we couldn't wait for it end. To get out of school, to move away from our parents, to leave the church, or the job, or the band, or the city that we're in, we can't wait. And then later, when we look back, there was something about that place that we hated that we just cannot get out of our system. These were, actually, just the most extreme possible example of that kind of thing. Literally, they were in a situation where people were trying to kill them and, when they look back, they think you know, that wasn't all bad.
这确实有点奇怪，但我不得不说这完全说得通。在某个时刻，我们所有人都曾处于某种境地，当时我们能想到的只有盼望它快点结束。比如早点毕业、搬出父母家、离开教会、工作、乐队或所在的城市，我们迫不及待地想离开。然后后来当我们回首往事时，那个我们曾经憎恨的地方，总有一些东西是我们无法从心里抹去的。这些实际上就是那种情况最极端的例子。从字面上看，他们处于一种别人试图杀死他们的境地，而当他们回首往事时，他们会想，你知道吗，那还不算太坏。
Well, you're listening to This American Life from Chicago Public Radio, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today, on our program, we bring you three stories of people leaving the fold and leaving parts of themselves behind when they do it.
嗯，你正在收听的是由芝加哥公共广播电台制作、公共广播国际发行的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，在我们的节目中，我们将讲述三个关于人们离开群体，并在离开时将自己的一部分留在身后的故事。
Act One of our show, I've Got A Secret I've Been Hiding From You. In that act, my friend, prepare to be shocked. We have the true story of Jerry Springer in his first career as a politician, an idealistic politician, who fought hard for what he thought was right and was popular to boot, successful.
节目的第一部分，《我隐藏的一个秘密》。在那一部分，我的朋友，准备好感到震惊吧。我们有杰瑞·斯普林格作为政治家的第一职业的真实故事，他曾是一位理想主义的政治家，为他认为正确的事情而努力奋斗，而且还很受欢迎，很成功。
Act Two, God And Hockey. In that act, a smack down between the God of the Old Testament and the New York Rangers for the souls of a young couple from New Jersey.
第二部分，《上帝与曲棍球》。在那一部分，一场关于上帝与旧约和纽约游骑兵队争夺一对来自新泽西的年轻夫妇灵魂的对决。
Act Three, Nuns Amok. Some nuns in the mountains of Appalachia decide they want to be nuns just without the Catholic church. Stay with us.
第三部分，《修女也疯狂》。阿巴拉契亚山脉的一些修女决定她们想成为修女，只是不想依附于天主教会。请继续关注。
Act One, I've Got A Secret I've Been Hiding From You. Chances are-- I think I'm pretty safe in guessing this, you do not think that you need to learn anything else about trash TV talk show host, Jerry Springer. You pretty much have an opinion about him. You know what you think of him. Our producer, Alex Blumberg, grew up in the city where Springer was Mayor years ago, and he put together this story.
第一部分，《我隐藏的一个秘密》。很有可能——我想我可以很有把握地猜测，你认为你不需要再了解关于垃圾电视谈话节目主持人杰瑞·斯普林格的任何事情了。你对他已经有了自己的看法。你知道你是怎么看他的。我们的制片人亚历克斯·布隆伯格在斯普林格多年前担任市长的城市长大，他策划了这个故事。
Jerry Springer arrived in Cincinnati in 1969 fresh out of law school with a job at a downtown firm. In just six months he announced he was running for Congress against the conservative incumbent. He was 25. He had no experience. Nobody had ever heard of him. But he was against the war in Vietnam, and he supported civil rights. And here's the thing you might not guess: he was fantastic. Patricia Garry and Jene Galvin are both Cincinnati political veterans. Here's how they remember him.
杰瑞·斯普林格于1969年刚从法学院毕业就抵达辛辛那提，在市中心一家律师事务所找到了一份工作。仅仅六个月后，他就宣布要挑战保守派在任者竞选国会议员。他当时25岁。他没有任何经验。从来没人听说过他。但他反对越战，支持民权。而且这里有一点你可能猜不到：他太棒了。帕特里夏·加里和吉恩·加尔文都是辛辛那提的政坛老手。他们是这样回忆他的。
He was, absolutely, the most gifted, natural politician I ever saw. And the grandmothers all loved him. The daughters all loved him. The brothers and sisters, everybody was a good friend of his. They were great. I mean, there was always a kind of a glamor around him where he was, clearly, a golden boy.
他绝对是我见过最有天赋、最自然的政治家。所有的祖母都爱他。所有的女儿都爱他。兄弟姐妹，每个人都是他的好朋友。他们太棒了。我的意思是，他周围总有一种魅力，很明显，他是个天之骄子。
I put Springer at the level of Ronald Reagan, Bobby Kennedy, Bill Clinton. He's that level.
我把斯普林格和罗纳德·里根、鲍比·肯尼迪、比尔·克林顿相提并论。他是那个级别的。
And it's not just local Cincinnati people who feel this way about Springer. Mike Ford met Springer back in the '70's, but has moved up in politics and is, today, a Democratic political strategist at the national level most recently hired to consult with the Dean Campaign.
而且不仅仅是当地辛辛那提人对斯普林格有这种感觉。迈克·福特在70年代就认识了斯普林格，但在政界步步高升，如今是一位国家级的民主党政治战略家，最近被聘为迪恩竞选团队的顾问。
I worked with Clinton, '90, '92. '88, Dukakis. '80, I worked for Kennedy. '76, I went through Birch Bagh, Morrie Udall and Jimmy Carter. He's the best I've ever seen, bar none.
我曾与克林顿合作过，90年、92年。88年，杜卡基斯。80年，我为肯尼迪工作。76年，我经历过伯奇·贝赫、莫里·尤多尔和吉米·卡特。他是最好的，没有之一。
Jerry! Jerry! Jerry! Jerry! Yeah!
杰瑞！杰瑞！杰瑞！杰瑞！耶！
Hey, welcome to the show. How you doing?
嘿，欢迎来到我们的节目。你好吗？
My guests, today, say they're cold-hearted mistresses who are proud to be breaking up marriages. Please meet Holly. She says she does more than just babysit her friend's three kids. Holly, what is going on?
今天的嘉宾说她们是冷酷无情的第三者，并为破坏婚姻感到自豪。请见见霍莉。她说她做的不仅仅是照顾朋友的三个孩子。霍莉，发生了什么事？
I've been screwing my friend's husband.
我一直在和朋友的丈夫鬼混。
It's kind of a long drop from wanting to save the world to hosting TV shows with titles like I Have Sex With My Twin and I Want To Be A Teen Stripper . The story of Jerry Springer is the story of an act of transformation so complete and so total that most people don't even know it happened. It's really the story of two Jerry Springers: one known only to a pocket of people in Southwest Ohio and as the heir apparent to progressive politics in America. The other known the world over as the king of trash TV.
从想要拯救世界到主持《我和我的双胞胎发生性关系》、《我想成为青少年脱衣舞娘》这类节目的电视节目，这中间的落差相当大。杰瑞·斯普林格的故事是一个如此完整且彻底的转变过程的故事，以至于大多数人都不知道它发生了。这实际上是两个杰瑞·斯普林格的故事：一个只为俄亥俄州西南部的少数人所知，作为美国进步政治的法定继承人；另一个则是全世界闻名的垃圾电视之王。
Go ahead, tell her.
继续，告诉她。
Theresa, I was screwing your husband. And he loves having sex with this.
特蕾莎，我一直在和你丈夫鬼混。而且他很喜欢这样。
Jerry! Jerry! Jerry!
杰瑞！杰瑞！杰瑞！
Well, he was Kennedy-like, very bright.
嗯，他很有肯尼迪的风范，非常聪明。
This is a comparison that comes up a lot when people talk about the other Jerry Springer, and it's no coincidence. The summer before Springer first ran for office in Cincinnati, he'd worked as a volunteer with Bobby Kennedy's presidential campaign. Here's Jene Galvin.
当人们谈论另一个杰瑞·斯普林格时，这是一个经常出现的比较，这绝非巧合。在斯普林格第一次在辛辛那提竞选公职之前的那个夏天，他曾在鲍比·肯尼迪的总统竞选团队中担任志愿者。这是吉恩·加尔文的讲述。
When Jerry got to Cincinnati, he had a Boston/Harvard/Kennedy accent. He doesn't have it anymore, but we got here, he had it. If you hear any old tape of him from that era, see any video clips, Jerry Springer came to town talking like Bobby Kennedy.
当杰瑞来到辛辛那提时，他带有波士顿/哈佛/肯尼迪的口音。他现在已经没有那种口音了，但我们刚到这里时，他有。如果你听到他那个时代的任何旧录音，看到任何视频片段，杰瑞·斯普林格来到镇上时说话就像鲍比·肯尼迪。
My campaign is based upon the proposition that the answers to the problems which currently plague our cities, our towns, and our homes, are not to be found in the decisions in Washington. They are, instead, to be found in the hearts, minds, and resources of our own people here at home.
我的竞选基于这样一个主张：目前困扰我们城市、城镇和家庭的问题的答案，在华盛顿的决策中是找不到的。相反，它们应该在我们家乡我们自己人民的心中、头脑中和资源中找到。
On old footage from this campaign, Springer looks even younger than He looks like a kid in one of his father's suits pretending to be Bobby Kennedy. But crowds loved him. He seemed like somebody reaching for something big even when he's talking about business prosperity and the gross national product.
在这次竞选的旧镜头中，斯普林格看起来比现在更年轻。他看起来就像个穿着父亲西装、假装成鲍比·肯尼迪的孩子。但群众很喜欢他。他看起来像是一个正在追求远大目标的人，即使当他在谈论商业繁荣和国民生产总值时也是如此。
The GNP, by itself, is no mark of our national achievement for it includes smokestacks that pollute, drugs that destroy, and ambulances which clear our highways of human wreckage. It includes a mugger's knife, a rioter's bomb, and Oswald's rifle. But, if the GNP tells us all this, there is much that it does not tell us. It says nothing of the health of our families, the quality of their education, or the joy of their play.
国民生产总值本身并不是我们国家成就的标志，因为它包含了污染的烟囱、毁灭性的毒品和清理高速公路上人类残骸的救护车。它包括抢劫者的刀、暴乱者的炸弹和奥斯瓦尔德的步枪。但是，如果国民生产总值能告诉我们这一切，那它也有很多无法告诉我们的东西。它对我们家庭的健康、教育质量或娱乐的快乐只字不提。
Springer was running in one of the whitest and most conservative parts of a very conservative city against a 10-year incumbent, and he lost that first race. It was the last time he would lose an election for the next decade. One year later, he ran for and was elected to the Cincinnati City Council. Tim Burke was his legislative aide on the council.
斯普林格在一个非常保守的城市中，最白人化和最保守的地区之一进行竞选，挑战一位任职10年的在任者，他第一次竞选失败了。这是他在接下来的十年里唯一一次竞选失败。一年后，他参加竞选并当选为辛辛那提市议会议员。蒂姆·伯克是他担任议员时的立法助理。
Jerry could go into a VFW hall and talk about why he was opposed to the war in Vietnam, and that was not a popular thing to do. He wouldn't convince VFW folks, at least not the majority of them, that they should come out against the war in Vietnam, that wasn't in their nature. But he'd walk out of that room and they'd like him.
杰瑞可以走进一家退伍军人协会大厅，谈论他为何反对越南战争，那可不是一件受欢迎的事。他无法说服退伍军人，至少不是绝大多数，让他们转而反对越战，那不是他们的本性。但他走出那个房间时，他们会喜欢他。
And this is the remarkable thing about Jerry Springer, the politician.
这就是作为政治家的杰瑞·斯普林格最了不起的地方。
Again, longtime friend, Jene Galvin.
再次有请老朋友吉恩·加尔文。
He has connect-ability that transcends specific viewpoints of people. He'd get votes from West-siders saying I don't agree with anything you say, but I just like your style. I like your guts.
他有一种能够超越人们特定观点的连接能力。他会从西区居民那里获得选票，他们会说我不同意你说的任何话，但我就是喜欢你的风格。我喜欢你的胆量。
The result of this was that, on City Council, Springer had an uncanny ability to bring a marginal message without actually marginalizing himself. Again, here's Tim Burke, Springer's legislative aide.
结果是，在市议会上，斯普林格有一种不可思议的能力，可以提出边缘性的信息而不至于让自己边缘化。再次有请斯普林格的立法助理蒂姆·伯克。
In 1971, when Jerry was elected to City Council, there was a proposal to build Riverfront arena, and the proposal was to do it with public dollars. And the original vote on council, as to how that was going to go, was an eight to one vote. Jerry was the only one who opposed it.
1971年，当杰瑞当选为市议会议员时，有一个修建河滨体育馆的提案，提案是用公共资金来建。议会对这个提议的最初投票结果是八比一。杰瑞是唯一一个反对的人。
Opposed doing it?
反对这样做？
Opposed doing it with public dollars. And the day of a critical vote, two members of Council were away. And it needed seven votes in order to meet certain of the procedural requirements. Jerry refused to give them the procedural vote, which had been the tradition. You don't hold something up on a procedural vote. You're free to vote against it on the merits, but you don't hold it up on-- well, Jerry bucked tradition, and then started just talking about why this was a bad thing to do, and we ought not to be publicly financing these things that ought to be supported by private business.
反对用公共资金这样做。在关键投票的那天，两名议员不在。需要七票才能满足某些程序要求。杰瑞拒绝按照传统给予他们程序性投票。你不会在程序性投票上阻碍什么。你可以在实质内容上自由投票反对，但你不会在——好吧，杰瑞打破了传统，然后开始谈论为什么这是一件坏事，我们不应该公开资助那些应该由私营企业支持的事情。
And, in the end, he captured the attention of the citizens of Cincinnati. They rallied to his side. The other politicians on Council got that message. And Riverfront Coliseum was built with private dollars, with very little public subsidy involved. And you don't see that happening in stadiums and arenas today.
最后，他吸引了辛辛那提市民的注意。他们集结到他这一边。议会里的其他政治家收到了这个信息。河滨体育馆最终是用私人资金建成的，几乎没有涉及公共补贴。今天你可看不到这种事发生在体育馆和竞技场建设上。
Oh, it really got you going, I'll tell you.
哦，我跟你说，这真的让你兴奋起来了。
Guy Guckenberger is a Republican and was one of Springer's Council opponents on Riverfront Coliseum funding. He said it wasn't any fun being on the other side of an issue from Springer.
盖伊·古肯伯格是共和党人，也是斯普林格在河滨体育馆资金问题上的议会对手之一。他说站在斯普林格的对立面一点也不好玩。
I mean, he'd make a public appeal and state a public position for an issue, and you either went with him or you were the bad guy. I mean, you didn't have any choice then.
我的意思是，他会进行公开呼吁并阐述一个问题的公众立场，你要么站在他这边，要么就是坏人。我的意思是，你当时根本没得选。
In 1974, Springer got elected to a second term with more votes than anyone else in City Council. Six months later, he resigned in a scandal. An FBI investigation into an illegal massage parlor across the river in Kentucky revealed that he'd been a repeat customer. How did they know? He'd paid for a prostitute with a check. Tim Burke was his legislative aide at the time.
1974年，斯普林格以市议会最高得票数连任。六个月后，他因丑闻辞职。联邦调查局对比河对岸肯塔基州一家非法按摩院的调查显示，他曾多次光顾。他们是怎么知道的？他用支票支付了妓女费用。蒂姆·伯克当时是他的立法助理。
We went something like 10 days in a row with the headline story in The Cincinnati Enquirer . Jerry was going through all kinds of personal hell, so was his wife, obviously. So was his family, as he had to call them and explain to them what he had done and what it was doing. And this was a young man with an absolutely terrific career ahead of him and it looked like it has all been destroyed.
我们大概连续10天登上《辛辛那提询问报》的头条新闻。杰瑞正在经历各种各样的个人地狱，他的妻子显然也是。他的家人也是，因为他不得不打电话给他们，解释他做了什么以及这会造成什么后果。这是一个前途无量的年轻人，看起来他的一切都被毁了。
And you, personally, what were your thoughts?
那么，你个人是怎么想的？
Part of it was what the hell were you doing? Why would you throw away this terrific political career you had in front of you for a few minutes?
部分原因是，你到底在搞什么？你为什么要为了几分钟的快乐而抛弃你面前这大好的政治前途？
At the time, it seemed that people weren't angry at the act as much as they were at the sheer stupidity of paying for it by check. But Springer was clearly shaken. The minute the facts became public, he resigned from Council. So quickly, in fact, that his colleague seemed a little shocked.
当时，人们似乎对这件事本身并不像对用支票付款这种纯粹的愚蠢行为那样生气。但斯普林格显然受到了打击。事实一经公开，他立即从议会辞职。事实上速度之快，以至于他的同事们看起来有点震惊。
I think Jerry would tell the story that his initial thoughts were I'm going to resign. I'm disgraced. I'm leaving town. I'm going to go start a new life someplace else.
我想杰瑞会说，他最初的想法是我要辞职。我蒙羞了。我要离开这个城市。我要去别的地方开始新的生活。
Within about 24 hours, he and his wife Micki, and his other friends decided that wasn't the way to do it. And he held another press conference. And he just said here's what happened, here's what I did, I'm ashamed of it, I apologize, and just came and bared his soul to the Cincinnati public. And they rallied to him again. It was amazing.
大约24小时内，他和妻子米奇以及其他朋友决定那不是处理这件事的方法。他又召开了一次新闻发布会。他说事情就是这样，这就是我做的，我为此感到羞耻，我道歉，然后就这样向辛辛那提公众敞开了心扉。他们再次支持他。这太神奇了。
Some of the nuns out at the College of Mount St. Joseph started a thing where they were sending stones and little pebbles to members of Cincinnati City Council trying to encourage them to reject Springer's resignation with the message he who is without sin should cast the first stone. It was tremendous the way that people responded to him. And that was, really, what started his comeback.
圣约瑟夫山学院的一些修女开始了一项活动，她们给辛辛那提市议会的议员们寄石头和小鹅卵石，鼓励他们拒绝斯普林格的辞职，传达的信息是：没有罪的人应该先扔石头。人们回应他的方式真是太了不起了。这确实是他复出的开始。
After a few months, Springer took tentative steps to get back into public life and manages another run for City Council. The Democratic party wouldn't endorse him, but they did leave a spot open for him on the ballot. Jene Galvin went with him to campaign.
几个月后，斯普林格采取了初步行动重返公众生活，并再次竞选市议会议员。民主党不会背书他，但确实在选票上为他留了一个位置。吉恩·加尔文陪他去竞选。
The Saint Patrick's Day Parade in Cincinnati, at the time, was huge, huge. It ran through the downtown streets. Thousands of people would come. You'd hope for great weather, and on this day we had great weather, a tremendous crowd.
当时的辛辛那提圣帕特里克节游行规模非常、非常宏大。它穿过市中心的街道。成千上万的人会来。你会祈求好天气，而那天我们赶上了好天气，人群非常壮观。
And as Jerry would come down through the crowd, they jeered him, they mocked him. And some of it didn't mean they wouldn't vote for him, but they mocked him. "Hey, Jerry. You got a check on ya?" "Hey, Jerry. You're really stupid, aren't you? Why'd you write a check?", just yelling all this stuff. And he would just sit there and smile and laugh and take it. And boy, my heart was kind of breaking for my buddy up on that back seat because I'm down driving this car. He just took a beating.
当杰瑞走过人群时，他们嘲笑他、讥讽他。这并不意味着他们不会投他的票，但他们嘲笑他。“嘿，杰瑞。你有支票带在身上吗？”“嘿，杰瑞。你真的很蠢，对吧？为什么要写支票？”就在那儿大喊大叫。他只是坐在那儿微笑、大笑并接受这一切。天哪，作为开车的我，心都要为后座上的老朋友碎了。他真是受尽了打击。
Still, the campaign worked. 18 months after resigning from City Council in disgrace and admitting publicly that he'd paid for a prostitute with a check, Jerry Springer was elected by the citizens of Cincinnati to a third term on City Council.
尽管如此，竞选还是成功了。在因丑闻从市议会辞职并公开承认曾用支票支付妓女费用18个月后，杰瑞·斯普林格被辛辛那提市民选为第三任市议会议员。
Two years later, back on the Democratic ticket again, he was elected Mayor, this time with the largest vote total in the city's history. It's not going too far to say that, less than four years after being caught writing a check to a prostitute, Jerry Springer had become the most popular politician in Cincinnati, ever, partly because he was able to mock his own stupidity. A rock and roll radio station convinced him to record a spoof commercial, a take-off on a popular credit card ad at the time.
两年后，再次出现在民主党竞选名单上的他当选为市长，这次是以该市历史上最高的得票数当选。说他在因写支票给妓女被抓不到四年后，就成为了辛辛那提有史以来最受欢迎的政治家，一点也不夸张，部分原因是由于他能够自嘲自己的愚蠢。一家摇滚电台说服他录制了一则恶搞广告，模仿当时流行的信用卡广告。
Hi. Do you know me? My face is seen all over Cincinnati, constantly. But when I travel, say across state lines, people don't know the difference between Jerry Springer and Gerry Ford, so that's why I carry this. The American Expense Card, it's the card that's good at thousands of clubs and motels across the river. I can even get instant, hassle-free check approval. For quick, enjoyable entertainment, it can't be beat. Just like me.
嗨。你认识我吗？我的脸经常出现在辛辛那提各地。但当我旅行时，比如跨越州界，人们分不清杰瑞·斯普林格和杰拉尔德·福特，这就是我随身携带这张卡的原因。美国费用卡，这是在河对岸数千家俱乐部和汽车旅馆都好用的卡。我甚至可以获得即时、无麻烦的支票批准。对于快速、愉快的娱乐，它是无与伦比的。就像我一样。
Most people, if they know the story at all, they know it wrong. They think Jerry Springer was Mayor, there was a prostitution scandal, he resigned, and then had nothing else to do but become the Jerry Springer of The Jerry Springer Show.
大多数人，如果他们了解这个故事的话，也是了解错了。他们认为杰瑞·斯普林格曾担任市长，发生了一起卖淫丑闻，他辞职了，然后除了成为《杰瑞·斯普林格秀》的杰瑞·斯普林格之外没别的事可做。
The truth is much stranger and more complicated. Jerry Springer became Mayor after the prostitute. And The Jerry Springer Show was a full decade and a half after that, during which time Springer left politics, more or less, on his own terms and then rose again to the top of an entirely different field-- television journalism.
事实要奇怪和复杂得多。杰瑞·斯普林格是在那次卖淫事件之后才当上市长的，而《杰瑞·斯普林格秀》是在那之后的整整十五年。在此期间，斯普林格多多少少按自己的方式退出了政坛，然后又在另一个完全不同的领域——电视新闻界——东山再起。
The president of the local teamsters union in Cincinnati and northern Kentucky is warning trucking companies to send trucks out in convoys after midnight on Monday.
辛辛那提和北肯塔基州当地卡车司机工会主席警告运输公司在周一午夜后让卡车组成车队出发。
This is Jerry Springer as he was known to Cincinnati and throughout the '80's-- local news anchor. Here's how he got there. In 1980, he stepped down as Mayor to run for Governor and lost in a tough, three-way race. When it was over, he was out of money and jobless, so he accepted an offer to anchor the local news at Channel 5, the lowest ranked local news program.
这就是辛辛那提和整个80年代所熟知的杰瑞·斯普林格——当地新闻主播。这就是他进入该行业的过程。1980年，他辞去市长职务参加州长竞选，但在三方角逐中落败。结束后，他没钱了，也没了工作，所以他接受了一份在第5频道担任当地新闻主播的提议，那是当地收视率最低的新闻节目。
In a fairly bold programming move, the station also let him end the broadcast with his own, nightly commentaries, which were often of a liberal bent: pro-union, anti-Reagan and Bush. He ended the broadcast each night with his signature phrase: "Take care of yourself and each other."
在一次相当大胆的节目调整中，电视台也让他用自己的每日评论结束广播，这些评论通常倾向于自由派：支持工会、反对里根和布什。他每晚以他的标志性短语结束广播：“照顾好你自己和彼此。”
Springer spent 10 years at Channel 5, during which he brought the nightly news from last to first in the ratings and earned 10 Emmy Awards. He attracted notice, including offers to host his own show.
斯普林格在第5频道工作了10年，期间他将晚间新闻的收视率从倒数第一提升到了第一，并赢得了10项艾美奖。他引起了人们的注意，包括主持自己节目的邀请。
In September of 1991, the first Jerry Springer Show was taped. Soon afterwards, Jerry Springer left Cincinnati for good. His final commentary on the local news is legendary.
1991年9月，第一集《杰瑞·斯普林格秀》录制完成。不久之后，杰瑞·斯普林格永久离开了辛辛那提。他在当地新闻节目中的最后一次评论具有传奇色彩。
OK. Bear with me. This'll be a little tough. You should know this isn't the first time I thought about leaving. I thought about it some 20 years ago when a check, that would soon become part of Cincinnati folklore, made me see life from the bottom. To be honest, the thought about ending it all crossed my mind, but a more reasonable alternative seemed to be hey, how about just leaving town, running away, starting life over someplace else? You see, in political terms as well as human, here in Cincinnati, I was dead.
好的。忍受我一下。这会有点艰难。你应该知道这不是我第一次想到离开。大约20年前，一张即将成为辛辛那提民间传说一部分的支票让我看到了生活的底谷，那时我就想过离开。老实说，结束一切的想法闪过我的脑海，但一个更合理的选择似乎是：嘿，为什么不离开这个城市，逃跑，去别的地方开始新的生活呢？你看，无论是从政治层面还是从人性层面，在辛辛那提，我当时已经死了。
But then, in probably the luckiest decision I ever made, I decided no, I'm staying put. I would withstand all the jokes, all the ridicule. I'd pretend it didn't hurt. And I would give every ounce of my being to Cincinnati. "Why, in time," I was thinking, "you have to like me or, if not like me, at least respect me." And I'd run for Council, even on endorse, and I'd prove to you I could be the best public servant you ever had or I'd die trying. Be it is a mayor, an anchor, or a commentator, whatever it took, I was determined to have you know that I was more than a check and a hooker on a one night stand.
但后来，在可能是我所做的最幸运的决定中，我决定不，我留下来。我要承受所有的嘲笑，所有的奚落。我要假装它不痛。我要把我生命的每一盎司都奉献给辛辛那提。“为什么，随着时间的推移，”我在想，“你们得喜欢我，或者即使不喜欢我，至少也得尊重我。”我要竞选议员，即使没有背书，我也要向你们证明我可以成为你们有过的最好的公仆，否则我死而无憾。无论是以市长、主播还是评论员的身份，无论需要做什么，我决心让你们知道我不仅仅是一个一夜情的支票和妓女。
But something happened along the way. Maybe it's God's way of teaching us. I don't know. But, you see, in trying to prove something to you, I learned something about me. I learned that I had fallen in love with you, with Cincinnati, with you who taught me more about life and caring and forgiving and also, most importantly, in giving, giving something back. Which is part of the reason I have been-- excuse me-- so sad this week, why it's so hard to say goodbye. God bless you, and goodbye.
但在过程中发生了一些事情。也许这是上帝教导我们的方式。我不知道。但你看，在试图向你们证明一些事情的过程中，我学到了关于我自己的事情。我学会了我爱上了你们，爱上了辛辛那提，你们让我学到了更多关于生活、关心和宽恕的知识，当然，最重要的是，关于给予，给予一些回报。这也是我这周——对不起——如此难过，为什么告别如此困难的部分原因。愿上帝保佑你们，再见。
Amy, you have a friend, Rusty. Let's now welcome him to the show. Here is Rusty.
艾米，你有一个朋友，拉斯蒂。现在让我们欢迎他来到节目。这就是拉斯蒂。
Oh, yeah.
哦，耶。
Go, Rusty!
去吧，拉斯蒂！
[LOUD THUMP]
[巨响]
[EXCLAMATIONS AND SCREAMS FROM AUDIENCE]
[观众的惊呼和尖叫]
Come on [BLEEP]! [BLEEP]!
来吧[消音]！[消音]！
It wasn't immediate, the switch from the nightly news to this. Originally, The Springer Show was meant to be the successor to Phil Donahue. And, indeed, the first year's topics included homelessness and gun control. Springer booked political guests like Oliver North and Jesse Jackson, and the show seemed innocent and upstanding. One early show bears the quaint title: Single People: On The Outside Looking In. But the ratings tanked, a new producer was hired and-- well, you know the rest.
从晚间新闻切换到这个节目并不是即时的。最初，《斯普林格秀》本意是菲尔·多纳休的继任者。事实上，第一年的主题包括无家可归和枪支管制。斯普林格预订了像奥利弗·诺斯和杰西·杰克逊这样的政治嘉宾，节目看起来很天真和正派。一个早期的节目有一个古怪的标题：单身人士：局外人。但收视率惨跌，聘请了一位新制片人，然后——嗯，剩下的你都知道了。
[SOUNDS OF AUDIENCE AND PEOPLE YELLING AND FIGHTING]
[观众大喊大叫和打架的声音]
For those in Cincinnati, those that know the other Jerry Springer, watching the show can be bewildering. Again, here's Patricia Garry who used to work with Jerry back in his City Council days.
对于那些在辛辛那提的人，那些了解另一个杰瑞·斯普林格的人来说，观看这个节目可能会让人感到困惑。再次有请曾经在市议会时期与杰瑞共事的帕特里夏·加里。
Well, first off, that doesn't look Jerry.
嗯，首先，那看起来不像杰瑞。
What is it about him, do you think, when you see him? What do you see when you're looking at him?
你觉得当看到他时，他身上有什么不对劲吗？当你看着他时，你看到了什么？
I don't know. Is he even in there? Where is Jerry? But he's still got that outward, you know, he can be happy with the microphones, and smiling, and all that. And then he does that little, pseudo-commentary at the end.
我不知道。他还在那里吗？杰瑞在哪？但他仍然拥有那种外在，你知道，他可以在麦克风前表现得很开心，微笑，等等。然后他在最后做那个小小的、虚假的评论。
Where is that positive energy? Where is that belief that he can make a difference? Where is that wanting to make a difference? That striving? He was always shooting upward. I don't know if that person is around.
那种积极的能量去哪了？那种认为自己可以有所作为的信念去哪了？那种想要有所作为的渴望去哪了？那种奋斗精神？他总是努力向上。我不知道那个人是否还在。
That's the thing, that seems to me, is that somebody with this gift, clearly--
在我看来，这就是重点，一个拥有这种天赋的人，很明显——
It's a Greek tragedy, isn't it? It's really a Greek tragedy. Yeah. I couldn't have written a better one: to end up being the joker instead of being the king.
这是一个希腊悲剧，不是吗？这真的是一个希腊悲剧。是的。我写不出更好的了：最终成为一个小丑，而不是一个国王。
Yeah.
是的。
I'm not conflicted because I know there's me and then there's the show.
我并不矛盾，因为我知道有我，然后有这个节目。
Jerry Springer might be the only person intimately familiar with Jerry Springer, who claims to feel no ambivalence about the place Jerry Springer has ended up. I talked to him in his office before he taped his show. It's hard not to like him. He's engaging, funny, but there's a certain practiced quality to the way he answers questions about his career choices.
杰瑞·斯普林格可能是唯一一个与杰瑞·斯普林格亲密接触的人中，声称对杰瑞·斯普林格最终的去处毫无矛盾感的人。我在他录制节目之前在他的办公室里和他谈过。很难不喜欢他。他风趣、幽默，但他回答有关职业选择的问题时有一种某种练习过的质感。
You know, I create this persona for the show. And that's what it is, I'm an act. Its like I'm in movies. No one goes after some actor because, let's say, he played Hitler in the movies.
你知道，我为节目创造了这个人设。事情就是这样，我是在表演。就像我在电影里一样。没人会去攻击某个演员，比如说，因为他在电影里扮演了希特勒。
I'm not saying anybody should have an issue with it at all. Here's a person who's, at every stage of their professional career, it's been imbued with a sense of trying to make a difference until you get to the Springer show.
我不是说任何人对此都该有意见。这毕竟是一个人在其职业生涯的每个阶段，都贯穿着某种试图有所作为的感觉，直到你来到《斯普林格秀》。
Well, we certainly made a difference in television. I'm not sure people are happy about it. I try not to think about it too much. Life is what it is. And you take what's handed and you work as hard as you can and, hopefully, you'll be successful. But I just don't spend too much time worrying about that. I do my show. I've always said it's a stupid show. I've had a wonderful life because of it and all that, but I've never, for a second, thought that it's important. It's trivial. It's chewing gum, and I recognize that. Once you do something that's significant in life, all this other stuff is just a way to eat.
嗯，我们确实在电视领域有所作为。我不确定人们是否为此高兴。我尽量不去想太多。生活就是这样。你接受所发生的一切，并尽可能努力地工作，希望你能成功。但我只是没有花太多时间担心这个问题。我做我的节目。我一直说这是一个愚蠢的节目。因为我拥有了美好的生活，诸如此类，但我从没想过它很重要。它是琐碎的。它是口香糖，我意识到了这一点。一旦你在生活中做了一些重要的事情，所有这些其他的东西只是为了混口饭吃。
From talking to Springer and his friends, I think the best answer to the question how did this idealistic, political guy end up in a job where he helps no one, is partly he stumbled into it and was as surprised as anyone about how big it got.
通过与斯普林格和他的朋友交谈，我认为这个问题的最佳答案——这个理想主义的政治家是如何最终得到一份对任何人都没有帮助的工作的——部分原因是他是偶然闯入的，并且对它变得如此之大感到和任何人一样惊讶。
Once the show started, what they euphemistically referred to as targeting the youth market, its success was both instantaneous and breathtaking. Within a span of a couple of years, Springer went from being just another talk show host to a worldwide phenomenon. The Springer show can be seen on televisions in over 40 countries, worldwide, including Tunisia. And when the show is named after you, you get a lot of the money. And the money really meant something to him. He'd come to this country when he was five, the child of Jewish refugees who escaped to America from Nazi Germany.
节目一开始，他们委婉地称为针对青年市场，其成功既是瞬时的，也是惊人的。在短短几年内，斯普林格从另一个谈话节目主持人变成了一个世界性的现象。《斯普林格秀》可以在全球40多个国家的电视上看到，包括突尼斯。当节目以你的名字命名时，你会赚到很多钱。这笔钱对他来说真的意味着什么。他五岁时来到这个国家，是逃离纳粹德国来到美国的犹太难民的孩子。
But there is some evidence that Springer is more ambivalent about his current job than he's willing to let on to a reporter. About four or five years ago he started making phone calls to his old friend, Mike Ford, who ran several of Springer's political campaigns, just to chat about politics. The more notoriety the show attracted, the more popular it became, the more frequently, it seemed to Mike, Jerry would phone him.
但有一些证据表明，斯普林格对自己目前的工作比他愿意向记者透露的要矛盾得多。大约四五年前，他开始给他的老朋友迈克·福特打电话，迈克曾管理过斯普林格的几次政治竞选，只是为了聊聊政治。节目吸引的关注度越高，它就越受欢迎，对迈克来说，杰瑞打电话给他的频率似乎就越高。
We talked, I would say, maybe, once a month, and it was always about getting back in. He would call me and he would say, so what are we going to do? And I would say well, I'm doing it. I don't know what you're going to do, but it's not happening on the show. And then we'd talk about options.
我们谈过，我想大概每个月一次，而且总是关于重返政坛。他会打电话给我，说，那么我们要做什么？我会说，我在做。我不知道你要做什么，但这不会在节目中发生。然后我们会讨论选择。
And we looked at everything. I went down to Mississippi to look at running against Trent Lott. We looked in New Orleans. We looked everywhere, but especially in Ohio. And he was feeling it out for years. He was empty, OK? That's the issue here. The show does not make him happy. It didn't fill his needs as a person.
我们研究了一切。我去了密西西比州考虑挑战特伦特·洛特。我们看过新奥尔良。我们到处寻找，但特别是在俄亥俄州。他试探了好多年。他是空的，明白吗？这就是问题所在。节目没有让他快乐。它没有填补他作为人的需求。
If you follow the news very closely, you may recall stories in early 2003 that Jerry Springer was considering a run for Senate in Ohio. Much of the national news reported this as a joke, the talk show fool trying to dress up as a statesman. But the small band of Jerry's friends from before knew the story was actually the opposite: a former statesman was trying to shake off the costume of a talk show fool. What this meant for Jerry was going around the state and speaking in front of as many Democrats as he possibly could. Jene Galvin went with him.
如果你密切关注新闻，你可能记得2003年初有关杰瑞·斯普林格考虑在俄亥俄州竞选参议员的新闻报道。大部分全国新闻把这当成一个笑话，谈话节目的傻瓜试图打扮成政治家。但那群杰瑞以前的朋友知道事实恰恰相反：一位前政治家正试图摆脱谈话节目傻瓜的戏装。这对杰瑞来说意味着走遍全州，尽可能多地在民主党人面前发表演讲。吉恩·加尔文陪他去了。
People say, would you come down Hocking College and speak? Yes. Will you come to the Mercer County Democratic Party dinner and speak? Yes. Will you come down to Athens County and help a young Ohio University woman running for City Council win an election? Yes. He goes.
人们说，你愿意来霍金学院演讲吗？是的。你愿意来默瑟县民主党晚宴演讲吗？是的。你愿意来雅典县帮助一位参加市议会竞选的俄亥俄大学女性赢得选举吗？是的。他去了。
I introduced him to the State Democratic County Chairs Association back in January.
我回一月份向州民主党县主席协会介绍了他的情况。
Again, Tim Burke.
再次有请蒂姆·伯克。
And, as I introduced him, you could just see that there was a great deal of skepticism in that room because, for the most part, the county chairs from around the state of Ohio only knew Jerry for this crazy television show he has.
而且，当我介绍他时，你能看出那个房间里有很大的怀疑态度，因为绝大多数俄亥俄州的县主席只知道杰瑞有这个疯狂的电视节目。
Many of you know him only as a host of some goofy television show. I know him as somebody who cares deeply about people, about politics. I'm proud to introduce you to my longtime friend, Jerry Springer.
你们中的许多人只知道他是某个愚蠢电视节目的主持人。我认识的他是一个真正关心人民、关心政治的人。我很自豪地向你们介绍我的老朋友，杰瑞·斯普林格。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Thank you, very much. May you never be on my show.
非常感谢。愿你永远别出现在我的节目中。
You could, literally, watch the audience change from skepticism to an audience that was laughing with Jerry.
你真的可以看到观众从怀疑转变为与杰瑞一起欢笑的观众。
The tax cuts proposed by the President are obscene. What the hell is he giving someone like me a tax break for?
总统提议的减税措施是荒谬的。他凭什么给我这样的人减税？
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
[笑声和掌声]
The argument for the tax package, and you hear it all the time, the argument for the tax package is to give people back their money so they'll spend it and will help the economy. Here's what's stupid. Rich people can already afford anything they want to buy. Do you think, if I get a check back in the mail, suddenly I'm going to buy something? If I want to buy something now, I'll go out and buy it. Don't give me the money. Take that money and make sure that every citizen in the United States of America has health insurance! That's where you spend the money!
关于税收计划的论点，你总是听到这个，税收计划的论点是把钱还给人们，这样他们就会花掉它，并帮助经济。这有什么蠢的？富人已经买得起他们想买的任何东西了。你认为如果我收到一张退款支票，我突然就会去买东西吗？如果我想买东西，现在就会去买。别给我钱。拿着那笔钱，确保美利坚合众国的每一位公民都有健康保险！那才是你花钱的地方！
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
If we would get that message across to the citizens of Ohio, I don't care how Republican your district looks, they will say, "Aha! That relates to me. Now there's a reason to sign up and vote Democrat." We've got to give them a reason. That's what we stand for. We are right on the issues. It just drives me insane when I watch the news and I see this garbage. Look, I'm the king of garbage, so I know garbage!
如果我们能把这个信息传达给俄亥俄州的公民，我不在乎你的选区看起来有多共和党，他们会说，“啊哈！这和我有关。现在有理由去注册并投票给民主党了。”我们必须给他们一个理由。这就是我们所坚持的。我们在议题上是正确的。当我看到新闻，看到这种垃圾时，我简直要疯了。看，我是垃圾之王，所以我知道垃圾！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And at the end of the speech, he had them all up on their feet. These are a bunch of hard bitten politicians who've heard lots of political speeches in their lives, and he had them on their feet at the end of the speech. He turned the room, just like that.
演讲结束时，他让他们全部站了起来。这是一群饱经风霜的政治家，他们一生中听过无数次政治演讲，演讲结束时他让他们全部站了起来。他就这样改变了整个房间。
You don't have to be a political strategist, however, to design the attack ad against the Jerry Springer Senate campaign. He airs one, himself, twice a day in most markets, for an hour each time. So along with the speeches and the candidate appearances, Mike Ford tried to research the question could Jerry Springer, the man, get beyond Jerry Springer, the show? Put it another way. Had Springer forever blown his chance to do the one thing he truly loved doing?
然而，你不必成为政治战略家来设计针对杰瑞·斯普林格参议院竞选的攻击广告。他自己每天在大多数市场播出一次，每次一个小时，一天两次。因此，除了演讲和候选人亮相外，迈克·福特试图研究这个问题：杰瑞·斯普林格本人能超越《杰瑞·斯普林格秀》吗？换句话说。斯普林格是否永远错失了他真正热爱做的那件事的机会？
We put together, more or less, focus groups. And we sat him in a room and, instead of asking questions directly about Jerry, we decided what we should do is, in effect, run a campaign before their eyes that was completely honest about all the things he'd ever done wrong or were distasteful, and then mixing them with the bio of the guy, and then letting him talk to camera about issues. We had impressive voices reading mean, horrible, nasty editorials. They had clips from the show. They had headlines about bad things. They saw all the bad, but then they saw a lot of the good.
我们策划了或多或少的焦点小组。我们让他坐在一间房间里，而不是直接问关于杰瑞的问题，我们决定我们应该做的是，实际上是在他们眼前运行一场竞选，完全诚实地说明他做错过的或令人反感的所有事情，然后将它们与他的个人简历结合起来，然后让他对着镜头谈论议题。我们有令人印象深刻的声音朗读刻薄、可怕、令人讨厌的社论。他们有节目剪辑。他们有关于坏事的头条新闻。他们看到了所有坏处，但随后他们看到了许多好处。
In every market we started horribly, and every single, one of them turned around in every audience, in every market. And the key thing there was that information is received in inverse proportion to its predictability. So if you said Jerry Springer is dating a llama, they would go yeah, yeah, I saw that in the Enquirer. But then you start unroll all this other stuff. And then, when he looked to camera and started talking about what's going on in this state and in the country, it was completely persuasive because it was all new.
在每个市场我们开始得都很糟糕，但在每个焦点小组中，他们都转变了观点，在每个市场都是如此。这里的关键是，信息的接收与它的可预测性成反比。所以如果你说杰瑞·斯普林格在和一只骆驼约会，他们会说，是啊是啊，我在《询问报》上看到了。但随后你开始展开所有这些其他的东西。然后，当他看向镜头并开始谈论这个州和国家正在发生的事情时，它是完全有说服力的，因为一切都是新的。
But there's one other thing they told Mike Ford. All the people in all the focus groups said the only way they could vote for him was if he quit his show. The voters, it turns out, could get beyond Springer, the show, to Springer, the man as long as Springer, the man, did it first. Which is what killed his exploratory bid in the end. He couldn't get out of his TV contract in time to start a Senate race, but he's still out there giving speeches. If you go to the website runjerryrun.com, you'll see five events with the Ohio Democratic organizations scheduled next month alone.
但他们还告诉了迈克·福特另一件事。所有焦点小组中的所有人说，他们唯一能投票给他的方式就是他辞掉他的节目。事实证明，选民可以超越斯普林格的节目，去认识斯普林格本人，只要斯普林格本人先这样做。这最终杀死了他的探索性竞选尝试。他无法及时从他的电视合同中脱身来开始参议院竞选，但他仍然在到处发表演讲。如果你去runjerryrun.com网站，你会看到仅下个月就安排了五场与俄亥俄州民主党组织举办的活动。
Springer's been thinking a lot about his message. He hits it in every speech he gives and it goes something like this: "We all believe, Republicans and Democrats alike, that the purpose of government is to provide protection. No one disputes that government should maintain a military or police force, or try to stop terrorists, but Democrats believe that government should protect its citizens from another form of violence as well."
斯普林格一直在考虑他的信息。他在他发表的每一场演讲中都强调这一点，内容大致如下：“我们所有人都相信，共和党人和民主党人一样，政府的目的是提供保护。没有人否认政府应该维持军队或警察部队，或试图阻止恐怖分子，但民主党人相信政府也应该保护其公民免受另一种形式的暴力。”
The violence of a pink slip on a Friday afternoon that says you've been laid off and now you don't have enough money to take care of your family. You know, job insecurity, the inability to get health insurance, that you have to choose should I take my medicine this month, or do I buy my kid a coat for the winter? So the Democratic party exists in America today to provide protection for middle and low-income America, particularly against economic violence as well as military violence.
周五下午那张解雇通知单带来的暴力，它说你被解雇了，现在你没有足够的钱去照顾你的家人。你知道，就业不安全，无法获得健康保险，你必须选择我这个月该吃药，还是给我孩子买件冬天的外套？所以民主党今天在美国的存在是为了保护中低收入的美国，特别是在对抗经济暴力和军事暴力。
Has doing the show for these last 8, 10 years, has it informed your political thinking in any way?
在过去8到10年做这个节目，在任何方面对你的政治思维有影响吗？
No. It's just confirmed it. Any job I've ever had it's been the same constituency, it's been middle and low-income people that need a voice, that need help, that need whatever. So, even in my entertainment, that's my base. In politics, it certainly was my base. When I practiced law, it was my base. This is who I am.
没有。只是证实了它。我做过的任何工作，选民基础都是一样的，都是中低收入的人，他们需要声音，需要帮助，需要任何东西。所以，即使在我的娱乐节目中，那也是我的基础。在政治中，那肯定是我的基础。当我从事法律工作时，那是我的基础。这就是我。
54 years ago, this week, I came to America. I was five years old. Most of my family had been killed in the holocaust in the camps in Germany and Austria during World War II.
54年前的这一周，我来到了美国。我当时五岁。我的大多数家人在二战期间德国和奥地利的集中营里在大屠杀中被杀害了。
The speech that you're hearing now is one Springer delivered back in January of 2003 to a group of Ohio Democratic county chairs. There was no press there. And the only reason we have it on tape is because an audience member recorded the whole thing on a personal tape machine from his chair. He probably thought that it'd be a joke, but he was so moved by the speech that he took the tape and had it duplicated at his own expense. He sent it around to all the county chairmen around the state, the idea being, here's a guy with a message for us.
你现在听到的这段演讲是斯普林格在2003年1月对一群俄亥俄州民主党县主席发表的。现场没有媒体。我们有录音的唯一原因是，一位观众从他的椅子上用个人录音机记录了全过程。他可能认为这会是一个笑话，但他被演讲深深打动了，以至于他自费复制了录音带。他把它寄给了全州所有的县主席，想法是，这是一个有话要对我们说的人。
In the speech, Springer gives his standard economic spiel and also condemns America's current foreign policy as arrogant and bullying. And then he ends with his own story of first coming to America with his refugee parents on a boat from Europe.
在演讲中，斯普林格发表了他标准的经济论调，也谴责美国当前傲慢和霸道的对外政策。然后他以自己和难民父母坐船从欧洲第一次来到美国的故事作为结尾。
We came over on the Queen Mary, January 19th to January 24th, a five day voyage over to America in 1949. And, when we arrived, my very first memory was my mom waking me up and saying, "Jerald, we have to go up on the top deck there." One of the decks of the Queen Mary. And all I remember-- because the rest has been told to me. I was only five-- but I vividly remember everyone standing out on top of the ship and the deck there-- there were about 2,000 passengers on board-- packed together, packed together. And what I remember, other than being freezing, is that nobody said a word. It was absolute quiet.
我们是1949年1月19日到1月24日乘玛丽女王号来到美国的，为期五天的航行。当我们到达时，我的第一个记忆是我妈妈把我叫醒说，“杰拉尔德，我们必须到上面的甲板去。”玛丽女王号的甲板之一。我记得的所有——因为其余的都是别人告诉我的。我才五岁——但我清楚地记得每个人都站在船顶甲板上——船上有大约2000名乘客——挤在一起，挤在一起。我记得的，除了冷得发抖之外，是没人说一句话。绝对的安静。
And we were passing the Statue of Liberty. And my mother told me later on, as I got older because, obviously, I wouldn't remember exactly what I'd said, but she remembers me asking her what are looking at and what does it mean? And she said, in German, eines tages, alles. One day, everything.
我们经过自由女神像。我母亲后来在我长大后告诉我，因为显然我不记得我到底说了什么，但她记得我问她我们在看什么，它意味着什么？她说，在德语中，eines tages, alles。总有一天，拥有一切。
The Statue of Liberty means everything. We take it for granted today. We take it for granted. Remember, the Statue of Liberty stands for what America is. We, as Democrats, have to remind ourselves and remind the country the great principles we stand for. This is a place of protection. This is not a country of bullies. We are not an empire. We are the light. We are the Statue of Liberty. Thank you for having me.
自由女神像意味着一切。今天我们把它视为理所当然。我们把它视为理所当然。记住，自由女神像代表美国是什么。我们作为民主党人，必须提醒自己并提醒全国我们所坚持的伟大原则。这是一个提供保护的地方。这不是一个霸道的国家。我们不是一个帝国。我们是光明。我们是自由女神像。谢谢你们邀请我。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
The elements aren't new. The immigrant experience, help for working people, the Statue of Liberty, but the effect was, somehow, electrifying for the people in that hall and the people passing around this tape. Wouldn't it be funny if, in the end, what the world really needs is more Jerry Springer?
元素并不新鲜。移民经历、对劳动人民的帮助、自由女神像，但效果对大厅里的人和传递这份录音的人来说，以某种方式令人振奋。如果最终世界真正需要的是更多的杰瑞·斯普林格，那不是很搞笑吗？
Alex Blumberg, he's one of the producers of our show.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格，他是我们节目的制片人之一。
Coming up, so a bunch of nuns and an Orthodox Jew walk into a bar. Actually, they walk into the second half of our show, and that happens just one minute, on Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，一群修女和一个东正教犹太人走进了一家酒吧。实际上，他们走进我们节目的下半部分，那只在芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际的节目继续时，在一分钟内发生。
This is American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, stories of people leaving the fold and, like Jerry Springer, having one part of them stays stuck back in the old days before they left.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是关于人们离开群体，并像杰瑞·斯普林格一样，让他们的某一部分停留在离开前的旧时光里的故事。
We have arrived at Act 2 of our show. Act 2, God And Hockey.
我们已经到达节目的第二部分。第二部分，《上帝与曲棍球》。
Shalom Auslander and his wife were raised in religious homes. But they were wobbling away from it, thinking of leaving the fold. But still, living in an Orthodox Jewish community in Teaneck, New Jersey, they were huge fans of the hockey team, the New York Rangers. And in 1994, The Rangers had an incredible season. They beat The Islanders, beat The Devils in a 7-game, double overtime win, went to the playoffs against Vancouver.
沙洛姆·奥斯兰德和他妻子在宗教家庭长大。但他们正在从中摇摆，考虑离开这个群体。但仍生活在新泽西州提内克的东正教犹太社区，他们是曲棍球队纽约游骑兵队的超级粉丝。1994年，游骑兵队度过了一个不可思议的赛季。他们击败了岛人队，在7场双加时赛中击败了魔鬼队，进入了与温哥华的季后赛。
And during one of these away games, fans could go, while the team was in Vancouver, for $5.00 and sit in Madison Square Garden and watch the game on the Jumbotron with other fans. But the problem for this couple was the game was on a Saturday and religious Jews don't drive on Saturdays, it's against the rules of their religion. Shalom and his wife really, really wanted to go.
在这些客场比赛中的一场，当球队在温哥华时，球迷们可以花5美元去麦迪逊广场花园通过大屏幕和其他球迷一起看比赛。但这对夫妇的问题是比赛是在星期六，而虔诚的犹太人在星期六不开车，这违反了他们的宗教规则。沙洛姆和他的妻子真的、真的很想去。
So this was push coming to shove in terms of the whole God existence thing. We kind of looked at each other, and I was all for going. I just said oh, to hell with it. My argument was if God got them in that position and--
所以这在关于上帝存在的所有问题上是一个推动因素。我们互相看了一眼，我非常赞成去。我只是说，哦，见鬼去吧。我的论点是，如果上帝让他们处于那种位置，并且——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
God made The Rangers winners.
上帝让游骑兵队成为了赢家。
God made the-- look, He brought over Messier from Canada. He brought over Kovalev from Russia. He really went out of his way to get these guys into this position to win, and it was probably a mitzvah to go watch them. You know, this commandment to go watch them.
上帝让——看，他从加拿大把梅西耶带过来。他从俄罗斯把科瓦列夫带过来。他确实竭尽全力让这些人处于这种获胜的位置，去观看他们可能是一个善举。你知道，去观看他们是诫命。
What was her argument?
她的论点是什么？
Her argument was fear, terror, God revenge. So her feeling was let's walk. It's about 14 miles from what we judged.
她的论点是恐惧、恐怖、上帝的报复。所以她的感觉是走着去。我们估计大约有14英里。
Wait a second. You actually thought that, if you drove instead of walked, that God would actually make the team lose?
等等。你真的认为如果你开车而不是走路，上帝真的会让球队输球？
I did.
我是这么想的。
That would be His revenge on you, really?
那真的是祂对你的报复吗？
Yeah. Yeah. Well, I certainly knew that, if it did happen, there would be a part of my head that went ah, nice going. Nice going. They play all season, and then you've got to go in the cab. And now look what happened.
是啊。是啊。好吧，我当然知道，如果它真的发生了，我脑子里会有一部分会想：啊，干得漂亮。干得漂亮。他们打了一整个赛季，结果你却得坐出租车去。现在看看发生了什么。
So let's walk from New Jersey into Manhattan, literally?
所以我们从新泽西走进了曼哈顿，字面上吗？
Yes. Literally.
是的。字面上。
Across the bridge.
穿过大桥。
Down Teaneck Road. You know, walk along the side of Route 4, which is this 8-lane, super slab highway, across the George Washington bridge. Walk down the highway, cross through Harlem, hit Broadway, and then it's 100 blocks down to Madison Square Garden.
沿着提内克路。你知道，沿着4号公路走，这是一条8车道的超级平板高速公路，穿过乔治华盛顿大桥。走过高速公路，穿过哈莱姆区，到达百老汇，然后还得走100个街区到达麦迪逊广场花园。
So we go and, as we're heading along, its turning out to be quite a longer walk than we thought it was. Particularly in our sabbath finest. And those are hard shoes. But her feet are slowly blistering. And its just getting worse and worse, and she's complaining more and more. It's at the point where she's taken her shoes off and walking. And I don't know how many of you have been in Manhattan, but that's a huge commitment to walk down a Manhattan street in just your socks. You've got to be in a lot of pain.
所以我们去了，当我们沿着路走时，结果证明这比我们想象的要远得多。特别是在我们安息日的盛装下。那鞋子很硬。但她的脚开始慢慢磨出水泡。情况越来越糟，她抱怨得也越来越多。到了最后她不得不脱掉鞋子走路。我不知道你们有多少人去过曼哈顿，但只穿着袜子走在曼哈顿的街道上是一个巨大的承诺。你一定是非常痛苦。
So, by the time we get there, the euphoria of the game took over, and it was just really great to be there. But we didn't really consider God much after that, until The Rangers lost. I think they lost 4-1. It was ridiculous.
所以，当我们到达那里时，比赛的快感占据了上风，能去那里真的很棒。但之后我们并没有真正多考虑上帝，直到游骑兵队输了。我想他们以4比1输了。这太荒谬了。
And the game just ended, and everyone just starts filing out, miserably. And we're just standing there just dumbfounded. Not only do we now hate the Rangers but, just theologically, we're spiraling. And the moment that final buzzer rang, my wife looked at me and said, "We should have driven." It was just that kind of-- all right, if this is the way He's going to play, if this is the kind of game He's playing, then we're not having any of it. And we left the Garden and I had a sidewalk hot dog. I was like, I'm strictly non-kosher from now on.
比赛刚结束，每个人都开始痛苦地散场。我们只是站在那儿惊呆了。我们不仅现在恨游骑兵队，而且在神学上，我们正在崩溃。终场哨声响起的那一刻，我妻子看着我说：“我们应该开车的。”就是那种感觉——好吧，如果这就是祂要玩的，如果这就是祂在玩的游戏，那我们一点也不奉陪。我们离开了花园，我吃了个街头热狗。我当时想，从现在开始我严格不吃犹太洁食。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Take that.
吃这个。
Yeah. How do You like that? Where can I get a Slim Jim around here?
是啊。你觉得怎么样？我在附近哪能买到Slim Jim？
And a milk.
还有牛奶。
Yeah, exactly.
是啊，完全正确。
I never thought about it. Like, this is the downside of having a personal relationship with God is that you'd constantly be bearing a grudge. I thought it was all just like reassurance and stuff from God all the time. He's there in times of need. I never thought you could actually just feel a grudge against him for something like this.
我从来没想过。就像，与上帝保持个人关系的一个弊端是你必须不断地记仇。我一直以为那只是上帝的安慰之类的。祂在需要的时候就在那儿。我从没想过你可以因为这样的事情对他产生记恨。
Well, you know, it depends what kind of God you're picturing. I came from a normally, incredibly dysfunctional, family with a pretty overbearing father. So, as a kid, you're going to these Hebrew schools. You're hearing our father who art in heaven, and I'm going oh, God, tell me there's not another one up in heaven. He's bad enough at home. He's bad enough at home.
嗯，你知道，这取决于你想象的是什么样的上帝。我来自一个通常极其功能失调的家庭，有一位相当专横的父亲。所以作为一个孩子，你去这些希伯来学校。你听到我们在天上的父，我当时想，哦，上帝，别告诉我天上有另一个了。他在家里已经够糟糕了。他在家里已经够糟糕了。
I realized that, as you said that, my image of God is exactly-- I could never put this together in my life-- is exactly my image of my father, but bigger, which is he's usually not around. Sometimes he'll take an interest. He means well, but mostly he's kind of like, you're on your own.
我意识到，当你那么说的时候，我心目中的上帝正是——我一生中从未能把它拼凑起来——正是我想象中我父亲的样子，但更大一点，也就是他通常不在身边。有时他会表现出兴趣。他的意图是好的，但大多数时候他有点像，你自己看着办吧。
Yeah. That wasn't mine. I wish that were my mine. Mine was a God in heaven, lumbering around in his underpants, half drunk on Chatham wine, looking to yell at somebody.
是啊。那不是我的。我希望那是我的。我的是一个在天上的上帝，穿着内裤走来走去，喝得半醉的查塔姆葡萄酒，到处找人咆哮。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So I picture that guy watching The Ranger game and going to hell with you, buddy.
所以我想象那个人看着游骑兵队的比赛，然后说，伙计，下地狱去吧。
Yeah. So you have this moment with the team. Does this actually have consequences past that week?
是啊。所以你和球队有了这一刻。这真的有那周之后的影响吗？
You know, I think it helped hasten the slide. The week after was the first time that we just ignored the fact that it was Sabbath. And I think our big God revolution, at that point, was to get in our car and go to a mall. And that was the big one for us. Sabbath was the big one. That's the hard one to get past.
你知道，我认为这加速了滑坡。后一周是我们第一次无视安息日这一事实。我认为我们伟大的上帝革命，在那一点上，就是上车去购物中心。那对我们来说是件大事。安息日是件大事。那是很难跨过的一道坎。
So this happened a decade ago. Have there been times that you missed being religious, having that life, having that community? Is there some part of it that you've missed along the way?
所以这是十年前发生的。有没有时候你怀念过宗教生活，拥有那种生活，拥有那个社区？一路走来，有没有什么部分是你怀念的？
No, because I gave up the practice of it. But it's funny, my family, or the people from that community, or anybody I went to school with, would look at me and say oh, he's completely irreligious and not spiritual at all. But the truth is I kind of feel like the most religious person I know because I still haven't quite gotten that God out of my head. He's still there. He still makes comments. There is always the picture of a big, old, frowning man, in the back of the room shaking his head, saying you're going to pay for this. So I could say I don't believe in it, but that's not going to get that character out of my life. And I don't know why I can't just give it up. I wish I could.
没有，因为我放弃了实践它。但很有趣，我的家人，或者那个社区的人，或者任何和我一起上过学的人，看着我会说，噢，他完全没有宗教信仰，一点也不灵性。但事实是，我感觉自己是我认识的最虔诚的人，因为我还没有把那个上帝从我的脑子里完全清除。祂还在那里。祂还会发表评论。房间后面总有一幅大而古老的皱眉男人的照片在摇头，说你要为这个付出代价。所以我可以说我不相信它，但这不会把那个角色从我的生活中清除掉。我不知道为什么我不能就这样放弃它。我希望能放弃。
Shalom Auslander in upstate New York. He has a collection of short stories coming out next year called, Beware of God.
沙洛姆·奥斯兰德，居住在纽约州北部。他明年将出版一本短篇小说集，名为《小心上帝》。
[MUSIC - "THE NEW YORK RANGERS' GOAL SONG"]
[音乐 - “纽约游骑兵队进球之歌”]
Act 3, Nuns Amok.
第三部分，《修女也疯狂》。
Now the story of some people who, absolutely, did not want to leave the fold and tried, in fact, to leave without leaving. This is in the 1960's, an order of nuns called the Glenmary Sisters. Susan Drury tracked down some of them to talk about what happened.
现在是关于一些绝对不想离开群体，事实上试图在不离开的情况下离开的人的故事。这是在1960年代，一个被称为格伦玛丽修女会的修女组织。苏珊·德鲁里追踪到了其中一些人，谈论发生了什么。
They didn't become nuns to escape the world. They didn't go live a life of cloistered contemplation. These women wanted to be Glenmary Sisters because they wanted a bigger, wider life. They wanted to get out of their hometowns. They wanted to serve the poor. They wanted adventure.
她们成为修女不是为了逃避世界。她们没有过上封闭沉思的生活。这些女性想要成为格伦玛丽修女，因为她们想要一个更大、更广阔的生活。她们想走出家乡。她们想为穷人服务。她们想要冒险。
Monica Appleby grew up in Chicago. When she graduated from her Catholic high school in 1954, she knew that she didn't want to be a nurse or a teacher or get married right away. A lot of her friends were joining the convent, but she was certain she didn't want to be like the nuns she knew from school. Then she got a brochure from the Glenmary Sisters and was intrigued by the photo on the cover.
莫妮卡·阿普尔比在芝加哥长大。1954年从天主教高中毕业时，她知道自己不想当护士或老师，也不想马上结婚。她的许多朋友都在加入修道院，但她确定自己不想成为她学校里认识的那种修女。然后她收到了一份来自格伦玛丽修女会的小册子，被封面的照片吸引住了。
Well, it's a sister who has a veil on and starched piece across her head, and only her face shows. But she is sitting at a tractor, driving. I thought it would be really neat to drive a tractor. And even for a sister to drive a car in those days was highly unusual. I heard later, though, that, that was a staged picture.
嗯，那是一个戴着面纱、头上顶着浆硬片子，只露出脸的修女。但她坐在拖拉机上，正在驾驶。我想驾驶拖拉机一定很棒。即使在当时，让修女开车也是极其不寻常的。不过我后来听说，那是一张摆拍的照片。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
That the Glenmary Sisters never did drive tractors.
格伦玛丽修女从来没有开过拖拉机。
The Glenmary Sisters were started in the 1940's. And their founder, Father Bishop, always intended that they would be a different kind of order. Unlike almost all other nuns in the US at that time, the Glenmary Sisters were not going to have hospitals, or schools, or any other institutions. Their job was to serve the poor, to just do whatever was needed in the poor towns where they were sent. Even more unusual, they were going to minister, not primarily to Catholics, but to people in places where there were few or no Catholics. To missions in rural parts of Appalachia where many people had never seen nuns.
格伦玛丽修女会始于1940年代。她们的创始人，比肖普神父，一直打算让她们成为一种不同类型的教团。与当时美国几乎所有其他修女不同，格伦玛丽修女不会拥有医院、学校或任何其他机构。她们的工作是服务穷人，仅仅在她们被派往的贫困城镇做任何需要做的事情。更不寻常的是，她们要传教的对象，主要不是天主教徒，而是那些几乎没有天主教徒的地方的人。到阿巴拉契亚农村地区的传教点，那里许多人从来没见过修女。
And, though they were cutting edge nuns, they were still nuns. They had mass every day and said their prayers three times a day. They studied theological books during meals and had silence every evening. These practices kept them grounded in their training and faith, they say, but other rules seemed to get in the way.
而且，尽管她们是前卫的修女，但她们仍然是修女。她们每天做弥撒，一天祈祷三次。她们在用餐时研读神学书籍，每天晚上保持沉默。她们说，这些做法让她们在训练和信仰中保持脚踏实地，但其他规则似乎成了阻碍。
Marie Cirillo joined the Glenmary Sisters in 1948, and says that one of the greatest obstacles to doing their work was that they had to wear the traditional habit. It was floor-length. It was gray wool. It had a veil.
玛丽·西里洛于1948年加入格伦玛丽修女会，她说她们工作最大的障碍之一是她们必须穿传统的修女服。它是及地的。它是灰色的羊毛。它有面纱。
And it had a cape on it. And, oh God, and I remember going up a hollow, getting out of the car, trying to climb up this mountain to this house. And the mother comes out. And the kids are on the porch and start screaming, "Mama! Mama! Witches! Witches!" And I think, God! I don't need this.
而且上面还有一件斗篷。哦，上帝，我记得走进一个山谷，下车，试图爬过这座山到这所房子。母亲出来了。孩子们在门廊上开始尖叫，“妈妈！妈妈！女巫！女巫！”我想，上帝！我不需要这个。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
And then another thing that was bothersome was that we couldn't eat with people. And if you're going out from the convent into the mountains and you're driving around, and you've packed your sandwich. But if you're stopping in a house and they want you to have something, and you can't do it. And then you have to go get in the car and start nibbling your food. You think this is so stupid, it's so stupid.
还有一件令人烦恼的事情是，我们不能和别人一起吃饭。如果你从修道院到山里去，你开车到处跑，你打包了你的三明治。但如果你在一个房子里停下来，他们想让你吃点东西，你却不能吃。然后你必须回到车里开始吃你的食物。你觉得这太蠢了，太蠢了。
That part didn't work at all.
那部分一点也不奏效。
Here's Monica Appleby again.
莫妮卡·阿普尔比再次发言。
The basis of our work was building relationships and, since we were so strange, it was finding a way for people to trust us. So that's why you would start questioning.
我们工作的核心是建立关系，因为我们太奇怪了，所以这是为人们信任我们找到一种方法。所以这就是你开始质疑的原因。
The timing was right for the questions they raised. In the early '60's, The Second Vatican Council was meeting to try to figure out how the Catholic church could adapt to become more relevant to the modern world. The pope asked every religious order to develop their own proposals for changes they thought would help them carry out their missions.
她们提出质疑的时机正好。在60年代初，第二次梵蒂冈大公会议正在召开，试图找出天主教会如何适应，以便与现代世界变得更加相关。教皇要求每个宗教团体制定他们自己的建议，以帮助她们履行使命。
The Glenmary Sisters were excited by the chance. The sisters proposed that they be allowed to participate in broader political work. They wanted permission to attend conferences on non-religious matters. And they wanted to be able to have secular people in their houses, to invite people for meals and fellowship. In addition, the sisters had begun to wear a modified habit: a two-piece suit with a short veil.
格伦玛丽修女们对这个机会感到兴奋。修女们提议她们被允许参与更广泛的政治工作。她们想要参加非宗教事务会议的许可。她们想要能够让世俗的人进入她们的房子，邀请人们吃饭和团契。此外，修女们已经开始穿改良的修女服：一套两件套的西装和短面纱。
It was one magazine article that changed everything. In July of 1966, The Saturday Evening Post ran an article titled The New Nuns. The tone of the article was admiring of the Glenmary Sisters, but the descriptions and photos of the nuns eating out at night, playing with children in alleys, showing their legs, did not go over well with conservative Catholics. Their Bishop was told to rein them in. And, by early 1967, they got word from Rome, the sister's recommendations for their order had been rejected.
是一篇杂志文章改变了一切。1966年7月，《星期六晚邮报》刊登了一篇题为《新修女》的文章。文章的基调是赞赏格伦玛丽修女的，但关于修女们晚上出去吃饭、在小巷里和孩子们玩耍、露出腿的描述和照片，并没有受到保守派天主教徒的好评。她们的主教被告知要约束她们。到1967年初，她们从罗马收到消息，修女们对她们教团的建议被否决了。
They would not accept, for one thing, the short habit. The cardinal said it showed too much bosom.
首先，她们不会接受短款修女服。枢机主教说它露出了太多的胸部。
Helen Lewis was a community college teacher in Virginia and worked closely with many of the Glenmary Sisters for decades. She and Monica Appleby wrote about them in a book called, Mountain Sisters.
海伦·刘易斯是弗吉尼亚州的一名社区学院教师，与许多格伦玛丽修女密切合作了几十年。她和莫妮卡·阿普尔比在《山地修女》一书中写了她们的故事。
The cardinal also said that they were acting as if they were the only agents of social change. He felt that they were a little bit, I guess, too uppity, or too arrogant or something, in making all these recommendations. And so they were ordered to go back to cloister, go back to all the old rules and regulations, go back to the long habit.
枢机主教还说，她们表现得好像她们是社会变革的唯一推动者。我想，我猜，他在提出所有这些建议时，觉得她们有点太狂妄自大，或者太傲慢之类的。因此，她们被命令回到修道院，回到所有的旧规则和条例，回到长款修女服。
The Church had asked them to weigh-in, had asked for their ideas, and then the Church had rejected those ideas, wholesale. In fact, by being ordered back to cloister, back into the traditional habits, they were given more restrictions than they'd ever had. And this is when they set out on a very unusual path.
教会在要求她们发表意见，询问了她们的想法，然后教会又全部否决了这些想法。事实上，通过被命令回到修道院，回到传统的服装，她们受到的限制比以往任何时候都要多。这就是她们踏上一条非常不寻常的道路的时候。
They decided they wanted to live as religious sisters without the Church, itself. They were going to quit but stay in Appalachia, serve the poor, and continue what they saw as their religious work. They were going to leave, not because they wanted a new life, but because they wanted to do what they had felt called to do all along. 70 of them quit and, of those 70, 44 started their own group they called FOCIS: Federation of Communities in Service.
她们决定想要在没有教会本身的情况下作为宗教修女生活。她们要退出，但要留在阿巴拉契亚，服务穷人，并继续她们所认为的宗教工作。她们要离开，不是因为她们想要新的生活，而是因为她们想要做她们一直感到被召唤去做的事情。她们中有70人退出了，其中44人组建了自己的团体，她们称之为FOCIS：社区服务联合会。
We had a meeting with this Father Becker, who was representing the Bishop, and we sat around a table dividing up the property and the goods.
我们和这位代表主教的贝克神父开了一个会，我们坐在桌子周围分配财产和物品。
And I do remember thinking that this is probably as close to the feeling of a divorce that I could ever have because it was like I had lived for 18 years with these women and then, all of a sudden, we had this split.
我确实记得当时想，这大概是我所能感受到的最接近离婚的感觉了，因为就像我和这些女性一起生活了18年，然后突然之间，我们就分道扬镳了。
The former sisters began building their new lives outside of the convent as members of FOCIS. They went back to work in many of the same towns and cities they had been in before.
前修女们作为FOCIS的成员开始在修道院外建立她们的新生活。她们回到她们之前所在的许多城镇和城市工作。
They elected Monica Appleby as their president. Monica's job was to raise some money and help this organization hang together. They had a ceremony and a special mass and made commitments to each other that mimicked the vows they made in the convent: chastity, poverty, obedience. Just as in the convent they wore special rings, but this time the ring signified their commitment to FOCIS.
她们选举莫妮卡·阿普尔比为她们的会长。莫妮卡的任务是筹集资金并帮助这个组织团结在一起。她们举行了一个仪式和特别弥撒，并向对方做出了承诺，模仿她们在修道院所发的誓言：贞洁、贫穷、服从。就像在修道院里一样，她们戴着特殊的戒指，但这次戒指象征着她们对FOCIS的承诺。
For many of the former sisters, this was the first time in their lives they lived on their own without their family or the Church providing for them. Now they had to buy clothes, keep bank accounts, find housing, and find jobs that would support them while they worked with the poor. They had to adjust to regular life in the secular world.
对于许多前修女来说，这是她们一生中第一次在没有家人或教会提供支持的情况下独立生活。现在她们必须购买衣服、开设银行账户、寻找住房，并找到能在她们服务穷人期间养活她们的工作。她们必须适应世俗世界的正常生活。
Just finding clothes to wear and figuring out how to dress, we would give each other suggestions.
仅仅是找衣服穿和想出怎么打扮，我们就会给对方建议。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It was kind of a teenage thing. I remember I went to Chicago and I got everything on sale. But I enjoyed picking out clothes. I picked out a green suit, I remember, that was polyester so it didn't wrinkle. Yeah. I thought that was real sharp.
那有点像青少年的事情。我记得我去了芝加哥，我买了所有打折的东西。但我喜欢挑选衣服。我记得我挑了一套绿色的西装，是聚酯纤维的，所以它不会起皱。是的。我觉得那真的很时髦。
So while the former sisters had decided they would live as nuns, they didn't look like nuns any more. And, as Anne Leibig tells me, that changed things, especially with men.
所以虽然前修女们决定她们会像修女一样生活，但她们看起来不再像修女了。正如安妮·利比格告诉我的，那改变了事情，尤其是对男人。
Before, we had to have it like you said. We'd see people, and we'd smile. And there wasn't anything sexual going on but, when I wasn't a nun any more, I didn't have to be a nun and I had regular clothes, I begin to sense that there was some different reactions from men as you'd smile at them and stuff. And then I started figuring out that there was something about flirting. I thought well, this flirting thing, I'd better learn about that.
以前，我们必须像你说的那样。我们会看到人，我们会微笑。没有什么性的事情发生，但当我不再是修女时，我不必成为修女，我有普通的衣服，我开始感觉到男人对你微笑时有一些不同的反应。然后我开始想，调情有什么东西。我想，好吧，这个调情的事情，我最好了解一下。
I think the hardest thing, and it still lingers a little bit, was that some people were so anti-structure anything that they just wanted to not be controlled in any way, or organize anything, or do anything together, just let me free because they had been so pinched with the structure. Well it's, I guess, maybe like in prison, you know? So I think that was the major tension.
我想最困难的事情，而且它仍然残留了一点点，是一些人对结构极其反感，以至于她们只是不想以任何方式被控制，或组织任何事情，或一起做任何事情，就让我自由吧，因为她们被结构束缚得太紧了。嗯，我想，也许就像在监狱里一样，你知道吗？所以我认为那是主要的张力。
The sisters didn't want to be obedient to any one person, so they had to figure out how to share authority. They also thought they could share money. Their plan was that those who could get paying jobs would make a budget for themselves, then send the rest of the money to the group to support some of the sisters who were doing unpaid mission work. But, as Helen says, it was a lot harder than they thought.
修女们不想服从任何一个人，所以她们必须想出如何分享权力。她们也认为她们可以分享金钱。她们的计划是那些能找到有薪工作的人会为自己制定预算，然后把剩下的钱寄给团体，以支持一些正在做无偿传教工作的修女。但正如海伦所说，这比她们想象的要困难得多。
It was hard for them to share money. Plus the fact that they had set up for themselves these meager budgets, just very small amounts of money for clothes and for gasoline and transportation, and so it just became not at all possible for them to do that. And I think that surprised them.
她们很难分享金钱。再加上她们为自己制定了微薄的预算，只有很少的钱用于衣服、汽油和交通，所以她们根本不可能做到这一点。我想这让她们感到惊讶。
And they didn't want to say they didn't want to share. And they didn't want to say they wanted to keep their own money if they were working for a job, but they needed it, you know. I mean, they were poor.
她们不想说她们不想分享。如果她们有工作，她们不想说她们想留住自己的钱，但她们需要它，你知道。我的意思是，她们很穷。
All the things they needed to keep going were things the Church used to provide, community and common purpose, organization and financial support, that made the work possible. They really couldn't make what they wanted, an order of sisters, without the institution, without the hierarchy, without the things that drove them crazy, so they struggled with obedience. They struggled with poverty. That left one more vow.
她们保持运转所需的所有东西都是教会曾经提供的，社区和共同目标、组织和财政支持，这些使工作成为可能。没有机构，没有等级制度，没有那些让她们发疯的东西，她们真的无法创造她们想要的——一个修女教团，所以她们在服从上挣扎。她们在贫困上挣扎。那就只剩下一个誓言了。
They had promised to remain celibate. And I don't think they intended to romance, but there were a lot of young men in the mountains who were in love with these sisters. I mean, they were intrigued with them and, I think, they had fantasies of romancing Catholic sisters. Maybe. I don't know. And so, very soon, they were being hit upon by some of these young men or, at least, being courted.
她们承诺保持独身。我不认为她们打算浪漫，但山里有很多年轻男人爱上了这些修女。我的意思是，他们对她们很着迷，而且我想，他们幻想与天主教修女浪漫。也许。我不知道。所以很快，她们就开始被这些年轻男人中的一些人搭讪，或者至少是被追求。
They'd left the Church in 1967. By 1969 they were making money, working regular jobs, and living apart from one another. Many were dating and married.
她们在1967年离开了教会。到1969年，她们正在赚钱，做普通工作，并且分开居住。许多人正在约会和结婚。
Finally, they all gathered together in Big Stone Gap and decided they didn't want to have an organization at all. They didn't want to do the fund raising. They didn't want to contribute from their own wages. They didn't want all the meetings where they'd make decisions together. And they didn't want to pay for a staff. As president, Monica was fired.
最终，她们都聚集在大石峡，决定根本不想拥有一个组织。她们不想做筹款。她们不想用自己的工资做贡献。她们不想开所有那些她们需要一起做决定的会议。而且她们不想支付员工工资。作为会长，莫妮卡被解雇了。
I remember it, distinctly, because it was at this set of three workshops that I organize. And I remember sitting in the room that was the dining room, where the big table was located, and screaming. And I made a scream like an animal. And I was just flattened, but I knew it was the right thing to do. I perfectly agreed with what people were saying. All those high ideals that we had weren't able to be materialized in the real world. All those pictures in my mind were changed.
我记得很清楚，因为它是在我组织的这一系列三个研讨会中的。我记得坐在那间是餐厅的房间里，餐桌就在那里，然后尖叫。我像动物一样尖叫。我当时被摧毁了，但我知道这是正确的事情。我完全同意人们所说的。我们所拥有的所有那些崇高的理想在现实世界中都无法实现。我脑海里的所有那些画面都改变了。
When they look back, Monica and the others don't think it was a mistake to leave the church and they don't really see FOCIS as a failure. Things evolve, they say. They continue to do the same kind of work, most of them, but on their own in social service jobs of different kinds.
回顾过去，莫妮卡和其他人并不认为离开教会是一个错误，她们也不认为FOCIS是一个失败。事情在进化，她们说。她们继续做同样类型的工作，她们中的大多数人，但以自己的方式在不同类型的社会服务工作中。
And many of them have stayed in touch. 23 of the former sisters along with their husbands, and partners, and children, are still members of a scaled-back version of FOCIS. They gather at least once a year to socialize, worship, and study together.
她们中的许多人保持着联系。23名前修女和她们的丈夫、伴侣以及孩子仍然是FOCIS精简版的成员。她们至少每年聚会一次，进行社交、礼拜和共同学习。
And now, as many of the members enter their 60's and 70's, they're wanting to try again and build one, last organization, a retirement center, a place where, as Monica says, they can live together, care for each other, and learn to age and die gracefully.
现在，随着许多成员进入60多岁和70多岁，她们想要再次尝试并建立最后一个组织，一个退休中心，一个莫妮卡所说的她们可以住在一起、互相照顾，并学习优雅地变老和死亡的地方。
Susan Drury lives in Tennessee.
苏珊·德鲁里居住在田纳西州。
Our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself with Diane Cook, Jane Golombisky, Starlee Kine and Sarah Koenig. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Kelsey [? O'Dell. ?]
今天的节目由亚历克斯·布隆伯格和我本人制作，黛安·库克、简·戈隆比斯基、斯塔莉·凯恩和莎拉·柯尼格参与。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作帮助来自托德·巴赫曼和凯尔西·奥德尔。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
You know, you can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife where they have Public Radio programs, best-selling books, even The New York Times all at audible.com. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
你知道，你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们节目的音频，他们有公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至《纽约时报》，都在audible.com。本节目由公共广播国际发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, he reminds you.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他提醒你。
'Til next time, take care of yourself and each other.
下次见，照顾好你自己和彼此。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "MARIA", THE SOUND OF MUSIC SOUNDTRACK]
[音乐 - “玛丽亚”，音乐之声原声带]
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。